Democrats vote to get rid of these white
rifles and the Republicans don't of
course Joy Behar had to defend Larry
David and disagree with you sonny
because I actually see Alyssa's Point
here I think there's a spectrum of
people that actually have nuanced views
on this is a complicated matter and what
Larry David did what I'm witnessing here
would be just a gotcha moment there's no
way to respond there's no way one I
don't think anyone's for murdering
children so that's just an over-the-top
statement and how are you going to then
dive into what you believe your gun
stance because we only get two parties
to pick from and sometimes they both
suck a little and so not equally so but
to me everyone has different reasons
they go for which party to reduce it
just to if you vote this way then you
must be this I just think that's
reductive Democrats vote to get rid of
these rifles and the Republicans don't
that's all we're saying
oh joy oh joyless brainless Joy um first
off the blonde whose name I always
forget and it's not worth knowing she
actually made sense she actually made
sense right like everything she said
there fully made sense credit to
nameless blonde person Joy Behar oh it's
the Democrats who just want to do the
Democrats just want to take guns away
from law-abiding citizens so obviously
they're the good guys here it's very
bizarre because none of these shootings
are ever done by members of the NRA
there are good guys who kill bad guys
with gun these are always people with
mental health problems remember that who
are they shooting that was one of the
most Twisted ones that we that we've had
in America and I think it was Ultimate I
think it was six uh 17 kids I mean
elementary school kids were killed and
two teachers if I'm not mistaken that
was the the shooting that the next day
uh Joy another Joy uh Joy Reid went on
MSNBC and said that this was not a
mental health issue this was a gun issue
and it's like that like the level and
that's the confusion that Joy Behar and
Joy Reed have I don't know what it is
with the name Joy but like first off if
you take more guns away then people
can't protect themselves and then bad
guys will be emboldened sunny Hosten
actually doubled down on it I mean as
you seize the opportunity how often is
Larry David going to be sitting next to
to Elon Musk who and it's just a
legitimate question you know Republicans
whenever there's a school shooting they
don't want us to talk about this is not
the time to talk about it well when is
the time until Larry stepped up and
talked about it four days after Karen
good for him this is my issue with it by
the way I think Larry David might be the
single funniest living person I'm a huge
fan I recently saw him on that brief
side I'm glad I didn't say hi because he
would not like me because I'm a
republican but here's my issue
here's my issue um I actually there's a
lot of things I think are very
legitimate criticisms of Elon Musk
platforming neo-nazis stoking
anti-Semitism stoking conspiracy
theories he's actually my understanding
is four background checks and I think
this is a bit of an intellectually cheap
argument to say you are Republican
therefore the blood of children is on
your hands like I think that is a bridge
waiting
party done recently to stem the title
because we actually passed a pretty
significant bipartisan
no they are not but he supports
background checks as do I and I don't
think it's fair to just say because you
vote with one party therefore blood is
on your hands I think it's just it
contributes to the like polarization of
Republicans are evil Democrats are good
or Democrats or evil Republicans aren't
like try to have a more honest
conversation there's a really big one to
have with Elon Musk about some of the
people he's platformed on you know you
lost me again I was like with you the
last thing exactly
all of a sudden that's why they call it
the view your view changes that's what
happens go ahead she lost me good listen
I completely agree with you I I think
you take the opportunity to call people
on it AR-15s are weapons of mass
destruction that should happen no place
in anyone's hands in this country and if
you vote Republican I believe that you
are complicit in that unless you are
actively working day and night to change
that within your party it strikes me
that Elon Musk is a little more
interested in his money he's a little
more interested in Tesla he's a more
interested in Neo-Nazi platforming on
Twitter or X or whatever the heck
because I can't use it anymore because
I've been suspended from it and I don't
even know why and I just think that you
know you have to really think when you
align yourself with a party as to what
that party is doing for you your family
your country and the Republicans in my
opinion right should be ashamed of what
they're doing the executive who hired
her at ABC should be ashamed everything
she said there was backwards from the
truth and again this thing that yes the
Elon Musk is making Twitter or X for
neo-nazis Sonny Hassan's been been
banned from Twitter suspended from
Twitter is that right is that right
where we've got 10 computers working on
that right now by the way the Uvalde
shooter who we referenced before and
that's what this was all about that's
what Larry David was pissed off about at
Elon muskover as if Elon Musk has
anything to do with you while they
shooting or anything else while they
shoot her passed a federal background
check to get gun okay he got the gun
legally we do have checks and you're
going to have there's no such thing as a
perfect system humans are imperfect so
we build imperfect systems
and I'm being told on the fly right now
that there is nothing to suggest that
Sunny Hosten has been banned or
suspended she's on Twitter right now so
okay so that was yesterday's view I
don't know what the high hell she was
talking about
which that should just be that goes in
perpetuity if somebody hasn't said
something I don't know what the hell
she's talking about